لما تتقارب بين الانتخابات في الولايات
المتحده والدورات الاولمبيه على اقل تقدير
من المنظور الزمني في عالم السياسه وتحل
انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه كل اربعه
اعوام وفي عالم الرياضه يكون هذا العام
موعدا اقامه دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه
الصيفيه
فاذا عدنا الى عام 2012 نجد ان المرشحين
متروني من الحزب الجمهوري وبراك اوباما من
الديمقراطيين تنافس على الوصول الى البيت
الابيض في ذات العام كان يصيب بولت يوصل
كسر ارقامه القياسيه مع جامايكا في
اولمبياد لندن
2016 عندما كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه
محتدمه بين دونالد ترامب كلينتون حصد
السباح الامريكي مايكل فيلبس في اولمبياد
ريو دي جانيرو 5 ميداليات ذهبيه ليصبح
ابرز رياضي في التاريخ اذا تقام
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كل اربعه اعوام
بالتزامن مع الالعاب الصيفيه وتقطع نصف
مده الرئيس الامريكي التي تبلغ اربعه
اعوام انتخابات التجديد النصفي كذلك الحال
في الالعاب الاولمبيه الصيفيه حيث تقطعها
في نصف مدتها دوره الالعاب الشتويه وفي
2014 خلال جديد النصفي عندما سيطر
الجمهوريون على الكونجرس بغرفتي كانت تجرى
دوره الالعاب الشتويه في سوشي التي احتل
فيها الرياضيون الامريكيون المركز الرابع
وفي 2018 خلال التجديد النصفي حافظ
الجمهوريون على الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
بينما ذهبت اغلبيه مجلس النواب
للديمقراطيين هذا التوازن
ظهر في دوره الالعاب الشتويه المقامه في
كوريا الجنوبيه لي حافظ الامريكيون على
المركز الرابع للدوره الثانيه على التوالي
اختتمت دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه الشتويه
2022 في بكين خلال فبراير الماضي ولم تشهد
مشاركه الولايات المتحده بسبب مقاطعتها
الدبلوماسيه من جانب اداره الرئيس
الامريكي
الاداره التي تواجه سباق الانتخابيه صعبه
مع الجمهوريين